it's thank you thursday and i believe
that every entrepreneur needs to take
time out to recognize the people in
their life
who are having a big impact or helping
them give them encouragement give them
ideas give them advice
and so today's thank you thursday is
nina
and nina has been a big part of my life
and has always been a huge supporter of
everything
that i do and i come with some crazy
ideas and i want to try some crazy
things and a lot of things don't work
out but
uh win lose or fail i always have nina's
support and she always has my back she
she believes
and i'm willing to try a whole bunch of
stuff and willing to fail at it and
and a lot of people are so afraid of
failing that they're not even willing to
try
and you have to be willing to go through
that failure and hopefully you have
people behind you who who support you
and have your back
so one quick story got a lot for nina
one quick story
i launched a new campaign under patreon
which you'll see in the link of all my
videos now in the description
and it's basically asking people to to
support me
it's you know if you like the videos you
understand that you know i make these
videos for free
i have cost and time and a team that i
support
and i do it to answer your questions and
motivate and inspire you
and so i ask for for support for help
and
it's basically a monthly subscription
you're paying as little as one dollar a
month whatever amount you want so i
launched the campaign
i didn't know if it would work right try
a bunch of stuff see what works
and be willing to fail and the next day
i woke up and i had my first
supporter and it was nina surprise
surprise
right she always believes in what i'm
doing and i'm forever grateful
to have somebody um like that in my life
who
who always has my back and always
believes
so thank you nina i love you for those
of you who are watching
i encourage you to take time today
on thank you thursday to find someone in
your life who
is is helping you right has given you
ideas is giving you feedback it's giving
you
motivation inspiration saying hey you
can do it because as entrepreneurs
we can't do it alone so take the time
out say thank you
believe for those of you watching you
like the video you can support me click
on the link in the description
leave a comment let me know what you
think and click on my face to subscribe
to the channel
thank you so much i'll see you soon